a new morning consult poll commissioned
by politico a left-wing outlet has
terrible news for democrats
republicans are trouncing them on almost
all of the important issues heading into
the midterms
on handling inflation voters favor
republicans over democrats 46 to 32
percent
on the economy at large voters trust
republicans 47 to 36 percent national
security republicans win 48 to 35
percent
immigration republicans win 45 to 38
on guns republicans take it by the same
margin
and on energy the parties are evenly
split but even those numbers don't tell
the whole story according to msnbc not
exactly a conservative outlet democrats
are in quote shellacking territory on
all three aspects of their midterm meter
presidential approval rating down at 40
percent
belief that the country is on the wrong
track that's all the way it's 71 percent
and the generic ballot which has
republicans up two percent doesn't sound
like a lot but it's actually pretty
significant when you look at all the
races even that
doesn't tell the whole story because
when you substitute in actual republican
candidates for the issues questions and
the generic republicans
in these polls the numbers look even
better for republicans a new poll of the
florida gubernatorial race has
republican governor ron desantis up
16 points on his nearest challenger that
would be the former republican current
democrat charlie crist desantis is up 19
points on his next nearest challenger
democrat annette tadeo and he's up a
whopping 24 points on the democrats
former favorite challenger nicki freed
if nothing substantially changes between
now and november the elections are
slated to be an electoral bloodbath for
democrats
republicans should run away with them by
every meaningful
metric if
the elections are fair and square
it's a big if
why aren't democrats changing strategy
on energy national security immigration
the economy everything else they're
doubling down on all the same policies
that are killing them in the polls
which can mean only one of three things
one
they don't want to win seems unlikely
two
they don't believe the polls i guess
that's possible
or three most disconcerting of all
they think they can win without the
votes i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles
[Music]
show welcome back to the show my
favorite comment yesterday is from eric
weininger who says as a washburn
university student i've been hoping
you'd stop by eventually it was very
hard to find information about your
speech we look forward to having you i
know i am speaking at washburn
university tonight in topeka kansas this
has caused something of a hullabaloo
not only are there planned protests i
guess from some of the radical left-wing
students but the president of the
university
jerry farley
has actually sent out an email
condemning me
preemptively before before i said
anything before i even arrived to give
this speech this is the man who
personally invited me to come speak he
signed the contract to invite me to
speak
today which today apparently is trans
visibility day he invited me on this day
and now he's trying to run away from
that and hide that fact and and say that
uh this is a horrible terrible thing
that i've provoked myself no i was
invited to come speak i was invited to
come speak on the issue of
transgenderism i look forward to doing
that actually after president farley at
washburn sent out this email condemning
me not exactly
hospitable behavior
after he did that i i made a proposal i
said listen president farley if you
think that my views are condemnable and
terrible and that i spread in his words
hate
and misinformation
well then i'm willing to share the stage
tonight
president farley if you are watching
this i am more than happy to share the
stage tonight at your university and you
can cite specific examples of what you
consider to be the hate and
misinformation that i've spread you can
cite those examples and we can discuss
them if if the issue that you've got is
with the thesis of my speech which is
simply that boys are not girls why you
can present your alternative thesis and
we can debate that as well i'll debate
the side that boys are not girls you can
debate the side that
boys are girls i guess and we can have a
respectful and civil debate
this is the spirit of free exchange and
uh
an open academic forum i would be more
than happy to do that or
or president farley can cower in his
administrative office and defame me
without stating any examples whatsoever
and try to run away from the fact that
he's the one who invited me in the first
place the choice is absolutely his i
have a speech prepared to give this
evening on transvisibility day but i'm
more than happy to throw that speech out
the window and have an open debate on
this question choice is yours president
farley if you're in the washburn
community please feel free to pass my
invitation along to him we've got to
protect
our academic discourse we've got to
protect our schools we've got to protect
our homes i say which is why you need
ring right now go to ring.com
knowles you know about rings video
doorbell i've told you about it for
years you get to see and speak to
whoever's at your door wherever you are
in the world that's amazing you probably
even know about rings home security
system it's an award-winning home
security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe super easy to install
you can do it yourself i need to hire a
contractor to screw in a light bulb even
i can install ring well now i've got to
tell you about the next level i've got
to tell you about how you can go pro
that's right ring alarm pro is according
to cnet a giant leap for home security i
think they're totally right
it helps protect me it can help protect
you and what ring alarm pro does is it
protects your whole home your physical
home
not just from bad guys but from freeze
from flood from fire your physical home
and your digital home it protects your
wi-fi it protects your home network it
protects everything it's that whole home
security system if you haven't done it
already gopro right now with a rings
award-winning alarm go to ring.com slash
knowles k-w-l-e-s that is ring.com
knowles
if the elections are fair and square
then
the republicans are slated to run away
with them
that's a big if isn't it you know part
of this show was censored yesterday
the show was not censored on apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play on
the audio podcast platforms the show was
not censored on the daily wire so if
you're a daily wire member you got the
full show but if you were on some of the
social media platforms
youtube
facebook this show was in part censored
not through my own desire
not through the desire of the daily wire
but because this show
fell afoul of the guidelines
you see there was an article published
in real clear politics this is a very
mainstream news outlet
citing a peer-reviewed scientific study
of the 2020 election
that raised some questions
about
the possibility of voter fraud and a
stolen election and it was an academic
analysis it's peer-reviewed it checked
all the boxes that we're told by the
left we need to check was highly
scientific
but because it contradicted the leftist
narrative about the 2020 election namely
that you're not allowed to raise any
questions really whatsoever certainly
about the outcome of the election you're
simply not allowed to to suggest that
that maybe something was off there
that my reading this peer-reviewed
scientific study
fell foul of the algorithm we were not
allowed to do it so one it's a reminder
that if you want to get the full show
you got to subscribe to the audio
podcast or better yet subscribe to daily
wire but
two it shows you just
the degree of
censorship that we've got in this
country right now and we're not just
talking about censorship of obscenity
censorship of
threats censorship of things that are
ordinarily censored the point of the
first amendment is to protect political
speech
and here we are seeing the entire
liberal apparatus censoring
very relevant very important political
speech
so you're not we're not allowed to do
that i would i would not do it i can't
do it today i'm not
raising the question of whether or not
the election was stolen if you want to
raise that question yourself i would
recommend you go check out this paper
you can read about it at real clear
politics or go listen to the audio
version of yesterday's show at the very
least though what we are allowed to say
according to our big tech overlords is
that the election
was rigged
meaning
let's not we're not talking at all about
whether it affected the results of the
election but we can at least acknowledge
that the democrats changed the rules
before the election in most states
in some cases in a way that was
unconstitutional like in pennsylvania
where the the constitution prohibited
widespread mail-in ballots and yet they
did it anyway that was one way that they
rigged the election another way is that
big tech and the media censored relevant
information about the election most
notably the new york post story on
hunter biden's laptop
hunter biden's laptop was discovered at
a repair shop there was a ton of
compromise on it a ton of evidence of a
whole slew of crimes personal crimes
sexual crimes financial crimes
and this was blacked out you wouldn't
hear about it in the mainstream media
you weren't allowed to post about it on
social media you weren't allowed to
privately message it on social media and
now
how many days has it been
it's now it's been
532 days since that story broke since
that story was denied by the
establishment media now 532 days later
cnn is admitting okay it was real
so there's a lot of issues that the
justice department has looked into
including of course this laptop that
on the right wing has featured a lot of
a lot of stories about about hunter
biden we know the fbi has possession of
it and that they believe it is his
laptop that the contents of it are his
thank you cnn thank you for telling us
532 days later what we've all known from
the beginning
namely that the laptop is obviously real
it's full of a ton of photos of hunter
biden
it's got all his photos all of these
frankly the emails are more damning than
the photos because it shows
extraordinary political corruption
financial crimes not just from hunter
but implicating the whole biden family
and yet
when the story broke we were told
that this was
disinformation russian
propaganda and disinformation here's an
article article in breitbart 15
media personalities who immediately came
out and said this was a total lie msnbc
executive producer kyle griffin
said
this is not censorship
facebook is under no obligation to allow
a disputed report that appears to
contain disinformation to spread on
their platform so the executive producer
at msnbc said oh it's really good in the
weeks before this presidential election
that we're censoring
damaging content about one of the
candidates the publisher of inc
said basically the same thing no serious
journalist should fall for this
disinformation waja hot ali at the daily
beast this is russian disinformation
meant to harm our democracy shouldn't be
given platforms
uh truthfulfiction.com brook binkowski
uh it's it's easy to see who's committed
to pushing known kremlin disinformation
it's known she not even that she didn't
know if it was accurate or not she knew
for a fact it was disinformation
nbc news did the same thing they're
hacked materials part of a
disinformation campaign
ben rhodes at msnbc it's disinformation
washington post's max boot he's a fake
republican who he's a democrat but he
pretends to be a republican at the
washington post he said the right to
spread false russian disinformation
about american political leaders on
social media is not the hill i would
choose to dine so he's making the
affirmative claim this is false
the the
laptop the hard drive it's false it's
not real the list goes on and on we
don't have time to go through all of
them and they were completely wrong they
were
at the v at the very least they were
completely wrong probably they were
lying
and now 532 days later after biden's
been in office for more than a year now
we can admit absolutely it's true
we're still not allowed to suggest that
maybe the election result
was not totally legit
we're not allowed that's why i'm not
suggesting it
that's why i would i would never do such
a thing youtube
though though you might consider reading
about this on real clear politics raises
some interesting questions
the issue is not to relitigate 2020.
that's over
i don't think i don't think that we're
going to go to some court
and finally have all of this evidence
that
that by the way you could only get
through investigations through subpoena
powers that could not it could not
possibly have been done
before
january of 2021 this is why sometimes
you'll hear oh the courts threw out
these questions because there was no no
evidence right well you it would have
taken time to get the evidence and you
would have had to subpoena that and the
courts didn't want to get involved okay
it's not about relitigating that i don't
think president trump is going to walk
into office again in the middle of 2022.
but the reason it matters is
what about 20 what about the 2022
elections what about the 2024 elections
if there are structural problems here
in our elections
if people don't have faith in our
election system which by the way no one
does democrats don't republicans don't
huge proportions of both parties think
it's rigged and that people are cheating
well if we don't have faith in that
why do we think it's going to get better
republicans are crowing about these poll
numbers well the poll numbers only
matter if we can trust
the elections
we've got to stay
healthy as a democracy we've got to stay
healthy as individuals which is why you
need tessa mays right now go to
tessamays.com use promo code michael
t-e-s-s-e-m-a-e-s dot com promo code
michael it's the award-winning ranch
dressing
vinaigrette
all sorts of american-made wonderful
delicious tasting healthy food it was
started by these three brothers who had
a dream to share their mom's recipes
with the world tesames puts flavor and
quality above everything else and
because of that they became the number
one organic dressing brand in
the country all the products are made
right here in the good old usfa they've
got a wide variety of kosher whole 30
and keto products whether you're in the
mood for a creamy avocado ranch or a
light refreshing lemon garlic dressing
and marinade there is a testament
product for every occasion everyone
agrees this thing tastes great on
everything dipping wings pizza pouring
it over a fresh salad tessa maze makes
every meal better these guys are the
embodiment of the american dream they're
bringing manufacturing back to america
their products are incredible go to
tessamays.com promo code michael get 15
off all their products t-e-s-s-e-m-a-e-s
com promo code michael there's a real
problem with free speech
not just in this country but around the
world
we're talking about how the president of
washburn university is doing everything
he can
to keep me off of that campus sending
out the email
saying that he's condemning me before i
even speak saying that the words that
i'm spreading that boys are and girls
are misinformation it's a public
university so he has very little
recourse he can't actually keep me off
the campus but
you're seeing this at universities in
america you're seeing this on big tech
and throughout the main establishment
media i don't even want to call them
mainstream they're not particularly
mainstream at all
but so much so that a major political
story before an election presidential
election was completely censored what's
happening around the world throughout
the west germany has just made it
illegal
to express support for russia
in the ukraine war
this from the
german ministry of the interior quote
russia's war of aggression against
ukraine is a criminal offense anyone
publicly approving the war may be liable
to prosecution in germany this applies
to using the z symbol two german
security authorities are keeping an eye
on the use of the symbol
i'm not saying people should support
russia i don't i don't think they should
support the russian invasion of ukraine
i'm not saying
that
people
should
criticize ukraine
obviously they're ukraine's a corrupt
country too they're criticisms to be
made but i'm not saying
that at this moment when russia is
invading ukraine people should be
focusing on the criticisms of ukraine
though there may be a lot
i'm just wondering why does this have to
be illegal
why does germany have to make it illegal
to
criticize
ukraine or to express support for russia
what political goal is achieved by that
i am not a free speech absolutist i
wrote a whole book called speechless
about the limits to free speech the just
and prudent limits to free speech that
our founding fathers supported that have
existed throughout all of american
history i am far from his free speech
absolutist
but why do you why do you need to make
this illegal
does it not
suggest
an extraordinary weakness
in your country in your political order
that you need to ban
expressing support for a country support
that doesn't even seem to be
particularly widespread
this is how i feel about washburn
do you do you need to and not just
washburn i'm talking about all these
other schools i ironically or
coincidentally rather the last time i
flew into kansas city also to give a
speech about how men are not women i was
attacked and then the president of the
university apologized not to me but to
the students that i was invited in the
first place
for saying that men are not women i'm
not saying there can't be limits on
speech i think there should be limits on
obscenity i think there should be limits
on fraud i think there should be limits
on fighting words i think there should
be limits william f buckley jr one of
the founder of the modern conservative
movement he said that he saw no reason
to protect the liberties of a communist
or of a nazi
fair enough there
for much of american history at least
for a lot of the 20th century it was
illegal to be a communist
and and advocate for the overthrow of
the american system of government that
was illegal you could be prosecuted and
many people were i'm i'm all for but why
do we have to
ban
the suggestion that men are not women
why do we have to
why does germany have to outlaw
expressing
support for i don't support the war but
why do they have to
outlaw expressing some support for some
war involving countries that are not
germany why
seems pretty weak there's some good news
for free speech coming out of finland
the court has just clear cleared a
finnish official of hate speech this
finnish official
had the finnish parliamentarian paivi
rasanan i'm definitely mispronouncing
that and bishop johanna
is they sound sort of polynesian rather
than finnish but i don't speak finnish
they express the christian view of sex
and marriage
and because they express the christian
view of sex and marriage
they were accused of hate speech and
they were brought up on charges for that
luckily they just won the alliance 20
freedom
helped get them out
and frankly even this went much further
even than talking about sex and and
marriage the prosecution in this case
alleged that the use of the word sin
can be quote harmful
and demanded heavy fines you're not
allowed to say the word sin
according to this finnish prosecutor
now we see what this is really about
this is not about
free speech versus censorship
this is the thesis of my book speechless
this is not about free speech versus
censorship all societies are going to
censor certain things all societies are
going to have standards all societies
are going to have taboos things that
you're not allowed to say that's
inevitable that's been true everywhere
in the world and that's been especially
true in america
the question is what are you allowed to
say
what are you allowed to express
what standard are we going to hold
the
the the
court here in finland thankfully has
made the right decision
but the the argument against it was that
this was
going to result in a secular blasphemy
law
it's a kind of a contradiction in terms
of blasphemies when you
speak in an irreligious way speak out
against god
and secular blasphemy is
speaking out against god in a world that
imagines that there is no god
we've had blasphemy laws in america for
a lot of american history there were
blasphemy laws no one ever thought that
it contradicted the first amendment
the question is what are you allowed to
say
are you
what what are those standards going to
be and so we when we argue for these
things it's not enough to merely argue
for total free speech
say whatever you want do whatever you
want that's never existed anywhere it's
never going to exist that's the
mechanism by which the life took over
the whole culture what you have to argue
is an actual substantive vision which is
what we're going to be doing tonight at
washburn by the way we're going to be
arguing not just for free speech in the
abstract we're going to be arguing for a
substantive vision
of what
sex means
of what human nature is of what our
relationship to our bodies and the
physical world is we're going to be
articulating a way to end this
transgenderism madness once and for all
so i hope you tune in we're going to be
streaming it
i don't know if it's at the daily wire i
think it might be at the yaf youtube
channel yaf tv that'll be at washburn
university people have very thin skin
these days and some people are defending
that
in the new york times
roxanne gay an opinion writer
is defending thin skin the headline is
jada pinkett smith shouldn't have to
take a joke neither should you defending
will smith
and
opposing chris rock and she says this is
but she says this is not a defense of
will smith who does not need me to
defend him instead this is a defense of
thin
skin
she says that
in our culture we're told we need to
grow thick skin be able to take
criticism and certainly be able to take
a joke and not cry and whine and scream
and go smack people over it
and that's terrible
because this benefits the oppressors
and this upholds white supremacy and
this is especially terrible to black
women
yes she says these are all public
figures at the oscars
and imperviousness to criticism and
ridicule is a necessity for celebrities
but no matter how thick your skin is or
how much wealth fame and power you are
cosseted being the butt of a joke isn't
fun sometimes it's intolerable when you
are constantly a target of jokes insults
incivility and worse as most black women
are
she says the skin we've spent a lifetime
thickening can come apart we're only
human and so too are the people who love
us so it is a defense of will smith
smacking chris rock over the joke chris
rock black too of course but i guess
that it's an inconvenient fact for this
article and she says that especially
black women should not have to take a
joke
you do not need thick skin
in defense of thin skin
for everyone
i don't think so i don't think
that this woman would defend thin skin
for conservatives
for straight white men christian men i
don't i suspect
she would not defend that
i know she would not defend that because
the new york times attacks conservatives
every day specifically straight white
men attacks christians
every day
mocks us for our views of
zack certainly for our views of religion
generally for our views of society mocks
us all the time the left calls us
deplorable irredeemable bitter clinging
idiots
should do
do we have the privilege of the thin
skin there no of course not what the
left says is we we should be
ostracized from society
so it's only a defense of thin skin
for certain people
because it's not really a defensive thin
skin at all it's the same old friend
versus enemy identity politics that we
always get from the left the question is
not should you have fixed which you
should have thick skin by the way be
strong fortitude is a virtue okay
weakness is not a virtue fortitude is a
virtue i know we don't talk about the
virtues a lot these days but it's good
be strong don't be weak toughen up
to quote don corleone when johnny
fontaine is crying adam godfather i
don't know what to do you can act like a
man that's what you can do come on
toughen up buttercup
but what what this woman is saying here
is you know conservatives you need to
toughen up we're going to insult you
we're going to belittle you we're going
to try to
make you second-class citizens in
society
and we're also going to protect the left
from any criticism that you might have
that's a political strategy and it's not
to do with censorship or free speech
in the abstract it's not to do with
being very sensitive or being able to
take a joke the question is
who
has those rights and the question is
what kind of speech is going to be
protected in a world of woke razors sold
by men who cave to the demands of social
justice warriors you can now use a razor
that pivots but doesn't cave yes i'm
talking about the daily wire and our new
razor company jeremy's razors if you're
not one of the 45 000 americans who
already purchased jeremy's razors then
head on over to i hate harry's dot com
to get your founders kit and
subscription now the launch of our new
razer company has been extremely
successful because of this tremendously
positive response we're actively working
to expand jeremy's razors team in
nashville tennessee specifically
jeremy's razors is currently looking for
an executive vice president as well as a
director of consumer experience this is
a huge opportunity not only to sell
razors but to be on the front lines of
taking back power from corporations sort
of thing we have been calling for for
years if you're interested head on over
to dailywire.com careers this is your
chance to join us and help to run
the razer company that has sprouted up
overnight taking the country by storm
and stands to play a really important
role in our cultural battles we'll be
right back with a lot more
the new york times says that we
we do not need to get a thick skin and
take criticism lying down no no in
defense of thin skin we can all be
really really sensitive and we should
not take any criticism
meanwhile at ucla the race and equity
director is openly wishing for clarence
thomas's death
jonathan perkins director for race and
equity whatever that means at the
university of california los angeles
tweeted his wish that supreme court
justice clarence thomas would die after
he was hospitalized quote this whole
rule that we're not to wish ill on
people is silly uncle thomas they call
him an uncle tom because they because he
although he's a black guy
the the left refuses to call him a black
guy because uh clarence thomas has the
audacity to think for himself and not do
exactly what he's told by leftists so
because of that because he has fortitude
and intellect he's not a real black guy
according to them he's a white guy uncle
thomas is a sexist token who's committed
himself to making us all share in he and
his
treasonous wife's misery and he and his
i don't that doesn't sound super
grammatical but i don't expect much from
directors of equity and race and
inclusion or whatever fake job he has
i'm over it he's bad he's literally
endangered lives of countless of this
country's vulnerable populations
literally
he's literally done it
should clarence thomas have to take this
lying down should clarence thomas have
to grow a thick skin
a prob i suspect the new york times
would say yes he did not only does he
need a thick skin they'd probably agree
with the director of race and equity and
inclusion and diversity and gumdrops and
rainbows over at ucla
who is openly calling for this man's
death
shows you two just how meaningless these
slogans are it's the left always
embraces these slogans openness
diversity
liberation you know they just they use
these really vague free love what is
free love means just screwing around to
whoever you want and leaving them in the
lurch and then just not having any
responsibility but it sounds really nice
right love and freedom
and openness and diversity it sounds
really nice well so the the director of
equity
equity race inclusion diversity is just
this vicious bitter man who's calling
for the death of a supreme court judge
because he he disagrees with him
does clarence thomas need to
to grow a thick skin i guess i guess he
does according to these people
if you didn't realize it already i think
these sorts of comments should show it
to you this diversity equity inclusion
all this crap that has taken over the
country in recent years
it has to go away we have to ban it
we've got to get rid of it it's horrible
it's terrible for companies for schools
for the country at large it's leading to
extraordinary racial division sexual
radicalism it's just bad and none of
this should exist the people who hold
these jobs are complete idiots there
these people in a different life would
not be qualified to mop up after the
elephants at the circus okay these are
very dumb people with very low iqs and
very little education and they're making
six figure salaries because they're
cashing in on political correctness and
leftist politics and the left is willing
to hire them to do it because these are
the foot soldiers these are the guys who
are enforcing the left's regime not just
in the government but in corporations
and in the media and everywhere else
okay so they're willing to do it
we need to completely get rid of this we
need to send these these lowlifes back
to the unemployment line where they
belong
that no one is benefited from this and
some conservatives want to play nice and
they want to work on well maybe we can
we'll try to meet you halfway no there's
no meeting halfway the equity
inclusion diversity diversity equity and
inclusion dei needs to die as far as i'm
concerned as a as a political movement
and as a corporate and professional
movement in this country it's absolutely
terrible and one university is doing
just that point park university
is just
canceling
their office of equity and inclusion
this is a private college in pittsburgh
and they said they're just shutting it
down good stuff good on you point park
university absolutely wonderful
what what does the the equity inclusion
diversity office what do they even do
here's the mission statement from point
park university quote
the mission is to wholeheartedly foster
institutional equity diversity and
inclusion by raising awareness and
implementing strategies and tools to
shift mindsets and align all members of
the campus community with creating a
culture of appreciation acceptance and
inclusion for all individuals at every
level of the institution
i
i am willing to offer
a lot of money
i'd probably go up to five figures six
figures even
for someone who can translate that into
english and i'd be willing to wager that
kind of money because it's not possible
because it doesn't mean anything none it
doesn't it's just
corporate slogan speak gobbledygook
foster equity diversity and inclusion
what does that mean
by raising awareness that's actually a
communist term raising awareness
it really took on a
popularity during the 1970s with the
second wave feminists who would have
consciousness raising activities and
that comes from
marxists in the early 20th century and
even a little earlier than that so
raising awareness is just another
version of raising consciousness and
implementing strategies to shift minds
that shift mindsets to what
and align
members with a culture of
appreciation and acceptance for all
individuals oh for all individuals what
about clarence thomas doesn't sound like
diversity equity and inclusion wants to
include or appreciate clarence thomas
they want him to die
it doesn't mean any it's just this is
what this is what they say the mission
of the office of diversity equity
inclusion is to be really good and nice
and real it's really good and we're
really really good
do what we say
what what is that what is that it's
it's to push radical leftism get rid of
this stuff
yeah i
i do not know that i could send my child
to an institution whether it's a school
you know elementary school whether it's
a college that has a department of
diversity and inclusion and equity it
just means a department of radical
leftism
we've got to get rid of that and so once
we get rid of the left-wing terrible
institutions we've got to build up our
own
you know what happened yesterday if you
were tuning into the daily wire on our
youtube channel or at the daily wire
website you you heard jeremy's the god
kings really big announcement
we are not just attacking other
institutions we are coming on and we are
building up our own
we are taking on
disney take a listen because of the
great reporting of chris ruffo we got to
see
leaked footage from inside disney
of high up disney employees saying
things like we have a not so secret gay
agenda
saying things like we insert we we uh
make sure i get this quote right
we're adding in queerness
wherever we can and that quote no one is
trying to stop
the producer who was doing so another
executive within the company said if
anything we don't have enough
lgbtqia representation
in content made for very small children
so what are we going to do about it
well we're going to do the same thing we
always do we're going to build
alternatives americans have enormous
economic might they just don't have any
alternatives the daily wire is building
those alternatives and today i'm proud
to tell you that we will be launching
daily wire kits
[Applause]
daily wire kids i love it you right now
can help us build that future by going
to dailywire.com subscribe
if you want you can pay full price that
would be great we support it we're going
to need a lot of money in order to do
this stuff
but also we're so excited about it
if you use code to build the future
right now this probably won't last very
long but if you do it right now you will
get 45 off your membership which is an
extreme discount so i recommend you do
it i was talking to sweet little elise
about this when the disney news came out
disney is saying yeah we're gonna make
all of our content super duper trans and
gay and asexual and we're gonna put all
these super woke messages about sex and
race and everything in there and
alisa turns to me she goes
well mac mac and the brett said at least
we don't need to go to disney world
because my wife and i we're not huge
i know that some millennials like to
they they'll go to disney world and
disneyland even without kids they'll
just go on their own in their 30s
they'll just go to and that's fine look
i don't mean to knock it i don't want to
yuck your yum but that's not what elise
and i would like to do we're not huge
disney
fanatics so on the bright side we don't
have to go to disney world but it is
kind of sad for the kid you do you want
your kid to have a magical experience
you want your kid to have all the fun
wonderful cartoonish stuff that we had
when we were kids and that's gone okay
that world is gone when i was a kid i
loved pinocchio
i loved the snow white movie i loved the
lion king that was one that was made a
little bit more recently i really liked
these things
and that disney is gone now disney is
pushing almost exclusively they say
everywhere they can this radical woke
agenda and the reason this is so bad is
not only because it's going to confuse
your kid about sex and human nature and
race and all this kind of stuff
the reason it's so bad
is that
it's a bad story
we
naturally like stories about princes and
princesses we naturally like certain
stories that disney historically has
been able to produce those stories
resonate with us because they resonate
with with
universal tales about humanity they
strike us as true because they speak to
human nature and what wokeness does is
try tries to rewrite human nature you
see this most especially in the
transgenderism movement isn't the
transgenderism movement tries to say
human nature is the opposite of what you
think it is men actually are women women
actually are men and so when they
shoehorn this stuff into movies not only
is it damaging politically but it just
ruins the stories the stories are not
good anymore sweet little lisa said by
the time that a little june our little
son is is grown up enough to go to an
amusement park
we're not going to go to disney world
we're going to go to wire world
and i promise you i haven't talked to
jeremy about this but i know he's
thinking this i know he is thinking
we're going to build wire world and
there's going to be a big stuffed animal
andrew clavin walking around that you
can go hug and take pictures with
i i know becau because this is such an
opportunity from the left
big crisis means big opportunity that's
the bright side that's the silver lining
in politics half of this country
does not what more than half of this
country does not like the world crap
that the corporations are pushing and
that the government's pushing that
everyone else is pushing
60 of the country supports the parental
rights and education bill the 100 of the
liberal establishment and especially
disney hates florida's parental rights
and education bill which prohibits
teachers from peddling transgenderism to
five-year-olds
everyone in the establishment loves it
and the vast majority of americans
despite all of the propaganda from the
media the vast majority of americans
support the bill
so that's fine
we're looking around here at the daily
wire
and we're saying okay
if
disney and all these other stupid
corporations are spending billions and
billions and billions of dollars to
peddle their agenda which is unpopular
with the american people then we're
going to spend our
millions of dollars a relatively small
sum compared to the establishment we're
going to spend that giving people the
kind of content they like and what's
happened our company has exploded and
this i hope i'm not giving away a trade
secret but i don't think it's a real
secret here here's here's the amazing
strategy that's allowed the daily wire
to grow
give people content that is truthful
that speaks to the human condition that
is entertaining when we're talking about
entertainment content and don't cram
false
stupid ideas down their throats don't
force feed them whatever ideological
poison has to happens to be tickling
your fancy that day
and that's going to allow you to grow we
need you to do it so if you head on over
to daily work.com subscribe you could
build the future
you'll get 45 off
speaking of disneyland
speaking of
california
california has become the first state
to implement an actual reparation scheme
for black people
we've talked about it for years
this goes back to that old promise of 40
acres in a mule for the freed slaves
that didn't happen there have been
in effect
a lot of reparations programs over the
years that's what that's what a lot of
the civil rights programs were about the
new society great society rather
programs were about
that's what a lot of the affirmative
action programs were about so there
there has been a lot of money spent on
de facto
reparations but until now we haven't
really seen direct checks to black
people just for being black people
hundreds of years after slavery
well now we're seeing that in california
this california task force has has
okayed reparations for direct
descendants of enslaved black people but
but this doesn't make a lot of sense
this doesn't one because people tend to
have mixed race and there were
black slavehold holders act ironically
the the first
officially determined owner of an
african slave for life in america was a
black guy himself he was a black angolan
guy
so
that there it would be very difficult to
parse at exactly who gets the
reparations but moreover the argument
from the left on white supremacy and
intersectionality and critical race
theory is that
racism and the effects of slavery
don't only affect the descendants of
black slaves it affects all black people
that if you are black in america even if
you got off an airplane from nigeria
just yesterday you are experiencing the
the problems and effects of white
supremacy and therefore you are owed
some kinds of reparations as well so
even by the left's own arguments
this this program doesn't make a lot of
sense but it's it's very clear what it
is it's it's a payoff it's a bribe it's
a bribe from the left to a very specific
interest group to a faction not a
political party
in the high-minded sense of having a an
understanding and an agenda for the
common good but just an interest group
and a faction you say we're going to pay
you a little bit of money and you vote
for us and that's how it's going to work
deeply on american deeply wrong stupid
generally and by the logic
of the left but that's the way our
politics is going terrible legislation
being passed in california
really great legislation being proposed
in our nation's capital i've got to hand
it to lauren bobert
congresswoman bobert is
proposing legislation that would
recognize emma wyant as the winner of
the ncaa championship you already saw
governor desantis do this in the state
of florida now
lauren wants to do this at the federal
level
this has been co-sponsored by 21 house
republicans
and it's a a resolution simply saying
that this woman actually won the
tournament and
the winner of the tournament was not
that big hulking dude who is pretending
to be a woman
i love this
why you're going to hear from the left
and from the squishy republicans this is
a distraction this doesn't matter
who care we need to focus on important
things like tax cuts we need to focus on
important things like climate change
this is a pretty important thing
the way our society understands the
difference between men and women
is much more important than your tax
cuts
or the sun monster
or
any other number of political issues
it's really really important well lauren
bobert has no right to do this
lauren beauvert is no she does of course
she has the right she has authority
she's a member of congress
no the ncaa
gets to decide for all americans what a
man is and what a woman is no i don't
think it does
the ncaa has some authority that's true
just like corporations have some
authority
just like big tech has a lot of
authority actually but we the people
still have some authority
in the state of florida with desantis's
resolution
and in the us congress with lauren's
resolution
and we need to exercise that authority
if we sit around waiting for the ncaa or
the colleges or the what corporations to
come around and
get on board with our traditional point
of view we're going to be waiting a long
time
or we can exercise the only power we
have left at all in this society which
is through our elected representatives
absolutely the right thing to do emma
wyant
is the winner of this race i don't care
about women's sports i don't generally
care about college sports
at all
but i do care about this one because i
care about
what's true and i care about what's just
and i care about the reality of human
nature
emma wyant run that way won that race
by whose authority do i say that by the
authority of the us congress
by the authority of the state of florida
now not everything is going great in the
u.s congress madison cawthorne
is a young republican representative
he recently appeared on a podcast
to spill a little bit of tea about the
congress dish a little bit of dirt and
to make the claim that he's been invited
to orgies and seen members of congress
doing illicit drugs out in that swamp
the sexual perversion that goes on
washing out i mean it being kind of a
young guy in washington with the average
age of probably 60 or 70.
and i look at all these people a lot of
them that i you know i've looked up to
through my life i've always paid
attention to politics guys that you know
then all of a sudden you get invited to
like well hey we're going to have kind
of a a sexual get-together at one of our
homes you should come and i'm like what
what did you just ask me to come to yeah
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an orgy yeah
or the fact that you know there's some
of the people that are leading on the
movement to try and remove you know
addiction in our country and then you
watch them do you know a keyboard
cocaine right in front of you and it's
like wow this is this is wild and then
there's also kind of the whole
espionage aspect of what goes on washing
of you know so many people trade in
secrets and there's a currency to
secrets and so uh it's wild and then you
know there's members of the of the the
media the journalists who kind of will
keep nasty stories about you or about
other people on a shelf and then what if
you're about to kind of speak out
against something they don't want you
they'll come out and say well we're
about to drop the story of when you know
17 years ago you did x y and z and you
don't want us to drop that story to you
so we're going to bully you back into
this position
do you believe madison cawthorn
because what the establishment of both
parties has said and the media and
everyone else they've said how dare he
make these crazy stupid outlandish
claims this is insane there's no way
this is true
there aren't members of congress having
orgies this is completely made up
and when i saw that reaction from the
democrats and the republicans i thought
oh he's 100 telling the truth
he is if i didn't believe him before i
sure believe him now
then i remembered i said wait a second
katie hill was busted for having orgies
with her staff
like three years ago that wasn't even
that long ago and that was just the one
that became public
and that was only because we had
photographs of it
i have no doubt that what madison
cawthorne is saying is correct
i don't know how prominent it is i'm not
saying that every member of congress is
going and getting weird i'm not saying
that they're all doing a little nose
candy off their keys in the house
hallway or something like that
but
is there
promiscuous sex in washington for sure
illicit drugs even by people who work
for the government yeah for sure
just that one but just that one alone
just katy hill alone just within the
last few years of course this stuff is
happening
though madison has been forced into
walking this back
kevin mccarthy
who's the republican leader in the house
he has said
that cawthorne told him
that some of the remarks
were untrue
and exaggerated
now mattis as far as i can tell madison
cawthorne has not actually come out and
said that it was a lie or that it was
exaggerated but the house republican
leadership has come out and said no
people were very upset about this they
said name names if you're going to make
this claim name
names
and madison is not going to name names
because it would destroy his
relationships with these people
because it would immediately put him as
far outside of the swamp as he possibly
could because i bet not all of these
people are democrats but some of them
are republicans too
because he might be sued for defamation
this might be a long process and because
as madison catherine says
everyone's got dirt on everybody i'm
sure people have plenty of dirt on
madison cawthorn
everyone's got a past everyone's got
some dirt on them
and you i remember this a couple of
years ago the press tried to drop some
insinuations that corn was up to no good
and up to shenanigans 15 years ago of
course this stuff happens
it's a reminder to all of us too this is
one of the big reasons that the culture
is constantly pushing us to do drugs to
have weird sex to look at weird things
on the internet to go do
shameful acts
is is because it's compromising it
compromises ourselves it makes it much
much easier to control people
especially in a world of 24 7
surveillance everywhere on your
electronic devices on cameras and we
have bugs everywhere in the country
right now
and this is the way
power has worked in washington forever
and it's it's hasn't just changed
overnight
the the
issue of regaining some control over our
political system
is a lot bigger than just going out and
turning out the vote there are a lot of
power centers in this country corporate
tech
administrative deep state as we call it
and they've and they've got real control
and the reason that it's so hard to
crack is because they have real
they have real leverage okay and and so
if we want to be able to overcome that
we're going to need to be wise as
serpents and innocent as doves i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
north show see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the bend shapiro show we here
at the daily wear are ready to go to war
with disney to protect your kids plus
the biden administration sees record low
approval ratings as the economy teeters
on the brink of recession that's today
on the ben shapiro show give it a listen